welcome to Simon Dev this is the second
part on our terrain generation series
last time we covered height maps and now
we're going to take it the next step and
add what's called fractional Brownian
motion sometimes referred to as just fbm
along with purlins and simplex noise to
generate the terrain now the code is all
available on github so take a look if
you're interested the link is in the
description below and if anything
doesn't make any sense feel free to
comment below we'll look at a few topics
in this tutorial notably will cover
randomness like can we just use the
random function gradient versus value
noise Perlin noise and simplex noise
what they are what fractional Brownian
motion is and how it's related to
purlins or simplex noise and finally how
to put all this crap together into
something resembling terrain so first
off let's talk randomness feel free to
skip this part if you don't care that
much and just want to move on to using
Perlin noise you can generate a bunch of
random values using something like math
dot random and you can even make it
smooth by making a grid of points using
this and then interpolating between them
this is called value noise and yes you
can totally use this it's fine in fact
you could just make up your own
pseudo-random function that takes X Y
coordinates and using math dot random
generates interpolated values here all
right one that just takes X Y
coordinates generates four random values
based on those X Y coordinates and then
blends them together using bilinear
filtering the generated noise looks a
lot like Perlin noise this is called
value noise and in case you are
wondering yes you can use this instead
of Perlin noise it's fine it'll work
you'll get mountains and valleys and all
of that how is this different from
purlins or simplex noise well these
noises are what's called gradient noises
and generally how they work is by
instead of at each point generating a
random value they generate a unit length
gradient vector and the reason we do
this well there's no crazy theoretical
reason or anything beyond gradient noise
tends to just look better it tends to
result in better looking procedural
stuff and so everyone uses
so now you kind of know why we don't use
random values instead of Perlin noise
what's this simplex noise that you've
kind of heard about well so Perlin noise
is a gradient noise it was developed by
Ken Perlin in 1983 and it has no patent
simplex noise is another gradient noise
it was also developed by Ken Perlin but
in 2001 and it was patented by Ken
Berlin the advantage the simplex noise
the it's the newer shiny thing it's
faster now there's a third option called
open simplex noise again a gradient
noise it was developed by Kurt Spencer
in 2014 and there's no patent it was
largely developed to skirt the patent
problems around simplex noise so that's
the difference isn't a huge deal not
really if it's just a personal project
use whatever is handy and available
don't spend too much time on this so
then fractional Brownian motion Perlin
noise simplex Knorr procedural terrain
generation how do they all relate
together
first off often when you see mentioned
by people talking about terrain
generation they use layers of
overlapping noise this overlapping is
what is what's called fractional
Brownian motion Brownian motion just
refers to the sort of random motion of
objects over time and fractional
Brownian motion just means that every
movement isn't fully independent in
other words there's some memory to the
movement or you could think of it as
there's some sort of momentum to the
movement if you're moving in one
direction depending on the parameters
you can keep moving in that direction
with random changes stepping back to
just a 2d graph here's how some random
noise looks so some terminology to start
amplitude refers to the magnitude so in
the case of our graphs here as we tweak
the amplitude all that's happening is
that the range of values goes up or down
it's basically just a multiplier against
how big or small the peaks and valleys
are next is
frequency frequency and waves likes a
sound waves is how many of these waves
pass through a given point in a
specified time interval so low-frequency
sounds look something like this while
high-frequency sounds look more like
this it's not going to be any different
for our randomness if we lower or
decrease the frequency what happens is
that we get more random points in the
same interval so now that you know that
let's look at how to calculate the full
fbm or fractional Brownian motion the
code I'll show you
given the point X on the x-axis what we
do is loop and add layers of noise the
trick is after every iteration of the
loop we decrease the contribution so
what we're doing is every iteration of
the loop we're sampling the noise then
increasing the frequency but decreasing
the amplitude of the noise meaning the
noise changes faster now but it has less
effect and this is controlled by what's
called the Hurst exponent or persistence
as you may have seen it in other
tutorials and what we end up with here
is as we sum these up the graph on the
bottom keeps the overall shape of the
first graph but adds in progressively
smaller details from the rest you can
see from the first one here it's just
way too smooth like rolling hills which
is perfect if you're simulating rolling
hills but if you want say some craggy
rocks and jagged mountains this doesn't
work so in that case you increase the
number of octaves and voila you're
adding some craggy ninis to the rocks
here starting to look a little
mountainous now to turn this all into
terrain if you watched the last video I
showed you how to turn a height map
texture plus a tessellated plane into
some nice terrain well guess what the
only thing that we need to do to turn
noise into terrain is swap out the
height map texture for noise you could
think of it as instead of having a
height map texture you have a noise
texture that's infinite in every
direction so what we do here as we go
and now instead of using our height map
we're going to send noise to our terrain
generation function from the last time
and now suddenly we've got
better-looking terrain and you can of
course go and tweak the parameters all
you want
so if you want more Rolling Hills I can
go over here and play with the number of
octaves and the Train kind of smooths
out here if I go and play with the scale
the hills get bigger or smaller so now
it's kind of lumpy instead of being
these large rolling hills I can also
play with the height to make everything
bigger or smaller black unity here
controls how quickly or not the
frequency increases between each layer
the default is the frequency doubles but
you can play with it to increase or
decrease to see how it looks we've also
got our Hurst exponent or persistence
here and as you increase or decrease
that you can see the effect it has on
all the smaller details of the terrain
they're kind of coming in and out as I
slide this up and down
I also added an exponentiation parameter
which essentially just runs everything
through a power function at the end what
this does is kind of flattens out values
the overall effect it has on the terrain
is that the sort of rolling goes away in
favor of sharper peaks and flatter
valleys and finally here's a drop-down
where you can select between Perlin
noise or simplex noise I gave you an
option in the UI to choose either one
personally I find the simplex noise
looks a bit better at least in this app
but people have made some pretty sweet
demos with either in the past so again
don't make this a major sticking point
in your decision-making then about wraps
up part 2 of this we looked a bit more
in depth at noise fractional Brownian
motion and you got some background on
them all in the next update I'm gonna
start building this out into something
more infinite so we'll start looking at
how to add infinite terrain generation
meaning we won't just be stuck with one
chunk of terrain that ends abruptly but
you'll be able to move in any direction
forever with just more and more terrain
appearing for now I hope this was easy
to follow and if you enjoyed this video
and want to see more like it give it a
like and hit that subscribe button in
the corner also let me know what you'd
like to see in the future leave a
comment below with suggestions or
requests until next time cheers everyone